[Music]
today is your lucky day the chap
uploaded a new video and you found it
I'm joking it's your lucky day because
Islam is establishing a mega mid and da
Center and you have a unique opportunity
to be part of that so click the link
below and donate
now asalam alikum my dear brothers and
sisters in Islam and welcome to another
episode of our Ramadan Series in today's
episode we'll be addressing the claims
of a Christian Bishop known for his
unsubstantiated criticism of Islam Mary
Mary Emmanuel in the specific clip that
we have selected for today he attempts
to prove the authenticity of the Bible
he claims that multiple authors from
different times and places wrote the
Bible and yet all recorded the same
message that Isam Jesus Is God
furthermore he dismisses the message of
the Prophet sallallah alai arguing that
it's illogical to believe in someone who
came centuries after Jesus peace be upon
him let's look at some of his statements
and respond in kind you want me to
believe in someone that never saw Jesus
never lived with Jesus never walked with
Jesus over the one who walked lived ate
embraced Jesus Christ every single day
for 3 years and four months where is the
logic the one who was with the Lord said
this is God this is the Son of God this
is God himself he was crucified he was
buried and I saw him risen after the
burial those who wrote The Holy Bible
both Old and New Testament are over 40
writers it took a time frame of about
1,600 years to write the entire Bible
1,600 years to write the entire Holy
Bible the entire authors the entire
writers I I should say the entire
writers different level of Education
different background different times
different countries all of them wrote
the same
thing 12
Apostles they hugged him every day they
walked with him they lived with him they
documented everything that they
saw you want me to deny all this and
believe in someone that came six
centuries later so let's summarize his
claim why believe in Jesus as a prophet
instead of being God when those who
actually saw Jesus claim that he was God
Muhammed what do you say to such a claim
based on his Criterion he would
disqualify all of the New Testament
writers essentially from uh from this
because actually all new testament
writers have not been with Jesus there's
no evidence that Matthew Mark Luke or
John were disciples or anything of that
nature no biblical scholar worth his
salt would actually even say that right
and then you've got someone like Paul
who's the author of 13 books of the New
Testament and his ministry was somewhere
between Scholars say 15 to 35 years
after Jesus Christ once again never met
Jesus Christ most of the the theological
points that he's bringing forward is to
do with his visions that he's seen and
so on and so forth so according to his
Criterion he should not accept any of
the biblical texts because the biblical
texts many of them happened many many
years after like John maybe about 80 to
90 years after was written that's the
equivalent for example if I were to say
I've never I don't have a grandfather
that was or great-grandfather or a
father that was in World War I but I'm
writing now in 2025 something about
World War I as if I was an eyewitness
test you know account somewhere now me
and you started writing books in World
War I as if they were I eyewitness
testimonies the Absurd
of believing a testimony that has come
almost a century after the person and
the events is the the like the likeness
of it or the similitude of it is the
same as if me me and you started writing
books on the first world war H and we
had not actually uh been uh part of the
first world war so that's the first
thing I'll say a question that can be an
argument that they can make in this
regard would be that okay fine you don't
have what we would equate like this the
testimonies of the but if you have the
the Next Generation afterwards that's
still much more strong
than hundreds of years later there's no
chain of narration and that's what makes
the argument he says that there's no
chain of narration between these people
okay and for example the events of Jesus
that's why I said like for example if my
grandfather great-grandfather went to
World War I there'd be some level of
plausibility there maybe my dad was told
a story by his dad which was told a
story by his dad and I could still write
a book maybe you could are you saying
that Paul did not meet with the
companions of Isa Alam no I'm saying
that Paul did not meet Jesus he said
himself that he he was making the
argument that this did not be with him
etc etc that there's no difference of
opinion that Paul was not there with
Jesus okay that's established that's
established but would you would you
still not say that it is more likely
that he would have more correct
information because he met with those
who were so that's the the second point
now so the point first point is
according to the strict reading of his
Criterion all the all the um writers of
the new test be disqualified
the second point I would make is the
following his Criterion is wrong because
he wouldn't apply it to the New
Testament so for example if Jesus said
something about Moses even though Jesus
came after Moses would he consider that
to be less historically viable because
it wasn't close to the time of Moses no
because he would say that's Revelation
to Jesus so he doesn't understand that
the same thing that we say which is that
this is from God and therefore God
doesn't make mistakes and therefore if
God is narrating historical events of
the past he's doing so from a perfect
knowledge or a perfect wisdom yes he has
to apply the same principles because
there are many sayings in the New
Testament that refer to Old Testament
prophets and Old Testament prophets who
the New Testament writers and or Jesus
had never met so the same exact thing is
what you call a self-defeating argument
you would have to now reject on those
grounds if it's a historical case being
made those accounts by the New Testament
writers and or Jesus Christ that are
mentioned in the New Testament that
refer to Old Testament text so argument
number one on a strict reading of his
Criterion okay on a strict reading of
his Criterion the New Testament writers
would not be qualified to speak about
Jesus yes on a more loose reading of his
Criterion even then there's a problem
because he then you have Jesus Christ
and the New Testament writers talking
about Old Testament prophets which they
have never interacted with and there are
in many cases Millennia away from right
but because you believe it's Revelation
was inspired by God you accept it just
in the same way that we would say we
believe that quran's revelation we
accepted that's where the the fire is
and the argument is could I just make a
point there so if so what if they were
to respond that when Jesus is talking
about Moses or any prophet in the past
he is a true prophet of God that's why
he has that information but they reject
the prophethood of Muhammad sallam
therefore because in their eyes he's a
false prophet so they would not accept
his his teaching if it contradicts what
they have likewise they would say okay
you don't accept the teachings of M
Ahmed about about Jesus dying in Kashmir
and all of that because you reject him
as a false prophet sure so why would say
to that is that this is begging the
question or special pleading fallacy
because what we're saying is that if
you've set forward a Criterion yeah
which is that the Criterion is someone
has to see and be with it which is very
similar to what you would find in the
for example historical critical method
the HCM that is in the western academic
sphere then you can't now uh betray that
Criterion because you believe for
confessional reasons because that way it
makes it impossible for us to assess and
there's no middle ground at which we can
rationalize and assess truth your claim
essentially becomes unfalsifiable and if
it's unfalsifiable we can't prove it to
be true or false yeah so Still Point
number one and point number two stand
which is that number one his on a strict
reading of his Criterion the New
Testament writers would not be
acceptable the second point is um then
on when Jesus and the New Testament
writers talk about the altim prophets
they have no right to do so the third
point is even more egregious actually in
many ways because it relates to the fact
that he mentions I witness testimony but
what if and what when the eyewitness
testimony that he's talking about is
actually
contradictory so this is I mean there's
a plethora and I can't even get started
on the contradictions of the New
Testament and the contradictions related
to Jesus Christ and what he considers to
be an Article of Faith which is like for
example the crucifixion the resurrection
everything else but I'll give you one
example just to make the point yeah I
see you didn't get bored by The Champ
huh I like that but make sure you click
the link below and donate to the mega M
project I
mention so for example if you look at
Matthew chapter number 21 verse number
one there were two women at the tomb
Mary Magdalene yeah and the other Mary
okay whereas in Mark chap chapter number
16 verse number one there were three
women Mary Magdalene Mary Mother of
James and salom you yeah in Luke number
24: number 10 there's a group of women
Mary Magdalene Joanna Mary the mother of
James and others in John chapter number
20 verse number one only Mary Magdalene
is
mentioned who did see who did they see
at the tomb okay Matthew chapter number
28 verse number 2 to5 one Angel sitting
at the stone outside the Tomb in Mark
chapter number 16 ver number 5 one young
man sitting inside the Tomb in Luke 24:
number for two men standing inside the
Tomb in John chter number 20: number 12
two angels so how many people were there
what they saw contradiction
contradiction contradiction and let me
tell you something according to the
historical critical method any
reasonable historian would reject the
story altogether because of it therefore
your main Article of Faith which is the
crucifixion of Jesus Christ which is one
of the markers of differentiation
between Islam and Christianity that is
called to question by by the profound
and profuse contradictory statements
found in New Testament yes relating to
the witnesses how many people were there
what did they see and so on and so forth
I've just given one example literally of
so many examples I give of new testament
contradictions which would render it an
a historical book and or a book that is
Frau with problems to say the least so I
think at the end of the day every single
line that he said this Mr man man
he said is actually contradicted he's
actually making a case against uh
Christianity not Islam with it yeah true
he's helping us make the case he we've
given him the rope and now what he's
doing is essentially hanging himself the
intellectual hanging he's hanged by his
own rope this is what I have to say
about him and about that particular weak
argument for the veracity of
Christianity I think there was a
brilliant response Muhammad brothers and
sisters who are watching this response
to this false ACC
accusation we have seen these kinds of
Bishops deviating people towards
Christianity from the religion of Truth
and we cannot really sit by and allow
such false information to spread these
people are in need of theed of Allah
subhana wa tala they need The Message of
Islam to reach them and if we allow such
people to spread thisinformation and
make sure that Muslims or make sure that
non-muslims don't actually get the truth
about the prophethood of Muhammad sallah
alaihi wasallam then we all will be
sinful and to be part of such an
initiative yes that we are doing right
now where we are responding to these
false allegations it's such a good deed
that everyone should be part of you
could argue W you can actually make the
argument for that it's the best thing
you can do someone could say well
actually what do you mean by that
because humanitarian stuff the people
across the world now we don't want to
ever trivialize that or minimize that
that is true and that's why we do
obviously humanitarian work ourselves
we're Allied to many humanitarian
Charities and that's important yes
however bro when you think about the
fundamental message of all of The
Messengers and the prophets it was to
call people to the religion of Islam it
was to clarify The Message of Islam it
was to clarify the message of the Quran
or any other book that was sent to any
other Prophet before them so what I'm
saying is that in many ways da should be
the center yes it should be cuz through
da we get people we create people we
nurture people we build people who will
then give charity yes so actually in
investing in the dawa is investing in
the humanitarian stuff at the same time
and in Ramadan at this time where these
people are listening to this message I
will find it hard to believe that they
will not be donating I think a good
chunk of them now listen to what you
just said and say Subhan Allah you know
what I'm going to do it I'm going to do
it because we're seeing the fruits of it
because we're seeing people coming to
Islam because we seen people say in
Islam they're seeing that this is the
most necessary thing they can probably
do after praying today the prayers that
they do very important prayers and being
good to their parents and whatever this
might be the most important thing they
do in the whole day the most useful
thing they do to their Community the
whole day yeah pressing a link spending
five minutes thinking about other people
thinking about the da it might be the
best thing they do after the prayers and
being good to their parents and the
thing is we are all supposed to be
giving da and not everyone has that
mental capacity that our brother
Muhammad hijab has not everyone is
definitely
not not everyone is able to convey The
Message of Islam all the opportunities
what we have all the facilities that we
have the research facilities exactly so
the way that you can be part of
conveying The Message of Islam which is
an obligation upon the umah to convey
The Message of Islam all the prophets of
Allah subh were sent for this specific
purpose yes to convey the message of to
take people out away from into
worshiping Allah subhana alone and when
we have people like this who are
misleading people into yes they are it
is an obligation upon the um full
obligation to clarify the of Allah
subhana tala and you have the chance to
be part of that tremendous work that we
are doing here by a small donation if
you give or a big one or a big one yeah
don't give a big one man it'san let's go
for it why what's the problem be scared
that's true don't be
scared well that's true in the month of
Ramadan that's the best if you're not
going to beig if you're not going to be
generous in the month of Ramadan when
will you be generous this is the best
time for you to invest in your and in
the da by investing in the da you will
insh be pleasing Allah subhana wa taala
so brothers and sisters do not let this
opportunity go they will they will
regret it they will regret they will
regret it do it now guys honestly there
is no choice in the matter
Choice still your choice Brothers it's
your choice click the button Below guys
we have no to survive as a community
this is the only way forward let's go
guys let's do it see you guys in the
next episode and I hope you will have
donated by then in
[Music]